this is what the eye of hurricane ioda
looked like from the sky but on the
ground it brought more devastation to
central america
already battered by a major hurricane
two weeks ago
unleashed torrential flooding and winds
of 250 kilometers an hour on nicaragua
before reaching honduras on tuesday
it left the trail of destruction as the
military struggled to bring people to
safety
forty thousand were evacuated from their
homes in nicaragua
eighty thousand in honduras
we have nowhere to go we can only hope
that god will have mercy on us
landfall just 25 kilometers from where
hurricane
hayden hit two weeks ago killing more
than 120 people
this time the death toll might be
considerably lower
after iota was downgraded to a tropical
storm
the preliminary report we were given
deals with toppled trees
light posts and electrical lines also
roofs of destroyed homes
and businesses
first pushed over the colombian islands
of san andres in providencia on monday
it is the strongest storm to hit
colombian territory on records
i spoke with the mayor of providencia he
gave me information about the damage
which we were able to see from the
flight up to 99
of our infrastructure has been damaged
there's been an unprecedented number of
storms and hurricanes this season
it has turned out to be even worse than
we thought it started earlier and is
going to end even late
for example um continued flooding in
countries like guatemala or honduras
in nicaragua is going to affect the
incoming harvest
and we this will severely strain
subsistence farmers
and already whilst it's still early days
it is quite
it is quite clear that this will extend
the emergency even
into into into mid-2021
but for now the attention remains on the
still heavy rains that could bring
more flooding and deadly landslides in
the region's
already saturated soil alessandra
al jazeera